this video is brought to you by nebula
get 40% off our yearly subscription by
clicking the link in the description
after another Headline News accident the
737 Max feels like a cursed plane on the
5th of January 2024 the plane suffered
yet another incident when a door plug in
the fuselage of the plane ripped off at
16,000 ft the force of decompression
reportedly ripped the shirt off a
child's back and slammed the locked
cockpit door open searches for the
missing door plug over the weekend only
turned up iPhones which somehow survived
the fall to the streets of Portland
below thankfully none of the 171
passengers or six crew members on board
were seriously injured in part because
the seats directly next to the damaged
fuselage were empty after cabin pressure
was lost the pilots dropped in altitude
and returned for an emergency landing so
what exactly happened How could an
entire panel of an aircraft just rip off
like this to get some Clues let's first
see what the hell a door plug even is
door plugs are essentially structural
and cosmetic covers for empty door
frames they are options for the 7379
plane when an airline is purchasing the
aircraft if the customer wants a higher
maximum occupancy they can take the
option to have a functional door
installed in this doorframe this is
because the number of passengers allowed
in an aircraft is linked to how many
emergency exits there rare if they chose
for a lower occupancy they can opt for a
door plug as Alaska Airways did the door
plug is not a functional door it as the
name would suggest simply plugs the
doorway with a door- shaped plug you can
tell them apart from the outside as they
have full-sized Windows where actual
doors have smaller windows on the inside
of the plane you can't tell that the
door frame is there as the panels look
the same as any other panel this allows
a standard row of seats to be installed
in this location deactivating this exit
reduces the max occupancy of the 7379
from 230 people to
189 if an airline later decides to
increase the occupancy and operate more
like a Budget Airline like say Riner
where seats are placed closer together
they can later install a fully
functional door in this location it was
this door plug that ripped out of the
plane and the photos of the aftermath
are quite confusing using there was
remarkably little damage to the plane
these are stop pads and they are
designed to take the load of
pressurization from the cabin pressure
interfacing with the stop fittings on
the door plug had the door been truly
blown off you would expect these to be
damaged but they look very much intact
down here are hinges and straps that
allow the door to open at about 15°
during maintenance and at the top and
bottom corners of the door plug are
guide track roller pins that slide into
guide tracks in the door frame before
being secured in place by locking bolts
one in each guide track for the door to
open it would have to move downwards
past these locking bolts the door was
found on Monday 3 days after the
incident and it too seems to be in
remarkably good shape this to me
suggests that either the Fasteners
attaching the plug to the aircraft
fractured or they were improperly
installed perhaps the incorrect bolt was
used they were under tightened or
missing altogether and indeed early
reports from industry insiders that
United and Alaska Airlines are stating
that they have found improperly
tightened Fasteners on several aircraft
which would make a lot of sense for how
clean the brakes look so who's at fault
here it's of course too early to give a
definitive answer but the blame could
well be spread across multiple parties
Boeing does not manufacture these parts
themselves their subcontractor Spirit
Aeros system systems manufacture both
the fuselages and door plugs in Witchita
Kansas before delivering them by train
for final assembly in Seattle Washington
the door plugs are usually not rigidly
installed in this step because Boeing
removes them to install Interiors for
the final customer and then fully secure
the door plugs during
reinstallation this seems like the type
of thing that could potentially get lost
in communication between two separate
companies perhaps in some cases the door
plugs were never moved for this purpose
and whoever was in charge of
reinstalling the doors was not aware
that they were delivered in the
semi-complete state that's my working
Theory but again it's far too early to
State anything with confidence this is
just me employing Murphy's Law if
something can go wrong it will go wrong
or perhaps someone somehow managed to
not fully secure the bolts across
multiple planes that seems less likely
to me Boeing pressurizes the hulls to
150% of typical iCal air pressure before
delivering the plane as a safety check
so in theory this could have alerted
them to improperly sealed door plugs
however air pressure pushes the door
plug against the door stops and the
semi-in bolts could have held it in
place during the test but bolts can
vibrate loose over time especially if
they are not installed correctly that's
why this wire tie is installed it's
designed to stop the Fastener from
rotating loose there's a lot of
different methods for doing this like
locking washers and adhesives some blame
could also lay with Alaska Airlines the
initial National transport safety report
stated that that exact airplane had
three previous pressurization issues
where the pilots had to take action all
in close proximity to this accident on
December 7th January 3rd and January 4th
and reportedly the maintenance crew
simply reset the pressure warning lights
and system without performing any checks
for pressure leaks which could could
have been caused by this faulty door
plug Alaska Airlines knew there was an
issue with this plane and decided to
limit its operation over open water in
case it turned into a larger issue with
no emergency landing options nearby so
there appears to be some blame on Alaska
Airlines and the regulations that allow
them to Simply turn off warning lights
and assume that not flying over water
will keep them safe someone could have
easily died in this accident it's a
miracle no one near the door was pulled
out during the rapid
depressurization however most people are
pointing the finger at Boeing this is
not the first time the 737 Max has had
issues some of you may be familiar with
the 737s previous issues where new
higher bypass engines were installed
higher bypass engines are much larger
and much more efficient but Boeing had a
problem the 737 was too close to the
ground and they couldn't fit these new
higher efficiency engines under the wing
without elongating the landing gear so
they figured out a way of attaching the
new engines higher on the wing to the
point that the engine cowling is
actually above the wing surface and this
altered the stability and control of the
aircraft which caused the plane to be
minorly unstable with a tendency for it
to pitch upwards a major redesign of the
airframe to fix the issue would have
required recertification of the aircraft
and retraining for the pilots a timec
consuming and costly Endeavor that
Boeing's Executives wanted to avoid so
they installed a software instead that
automatically adjusted the planes
control surfaces to compensate for the
new instability which they called mcass
a software that malfunctioned causing
the plane to nose dive on several
occasions in some cases Pilots were able
to identify the cause and turn off the
malfunctioning system but on two of
those occasions Ethiopian Airlines
flight 302 and line airlight 610 the
malfunctions caused crashes killing a
total of
346 people all 737 Maxes were grounded
in the aftermath of the crashes Boeing's
then CEO Dennis mullenberg was fired
with a $62 million golden parachute and
Boeing paid $242 million in criminal
fraud penalties $ 1.77 billion in
Damages to Airline customers and 500
million to the victims of the crashes
these crashes deservedly damaged
Boeing's reputation showing that their
Executives were willing to take
shortcuts to increase Revenue although
the severity of the issue is clearly not
on the same scale many are joining the
dots and seeing a pattern with Boeing's
business practices over the past decade
Boeing recently requested that the FAA
exempt the 737 Max 7 from a safety
regulation so they could deliver planes
on time as they worked on a long-term
solution to an overheating problem with
the the engine a problem which they
asked the pilots to solve by limiting
their use of the anti- ice system to
just 5 minutes when flying in dry
conditions because the inlets around the
engines get too hot and could fracture
and strike the windows and cause a rapid
decompression just like what happened to
Southwest flight 1380 when a 737 NG
suffered that exact fate and a passenger
was partially ejected from the plane and
died as a result of her injuries this
was an older plane which is not affected
by this overheating issue which is
caused by the composite material
cowlings which is an issue exclusive to
the 737 Max but the potential loss of
life is the same to the recommendation
of limiting anti-icing system operation
to just 5 minutes a representative of
American Airlines Pilots said we're not
interested in seen exemptions and
accommodations that depend on human
memory there's just got to be a better
way loose bolts across multip multiple
planes is a sign of a systemic issue
once again something that should be easy
to add to a checklist and have a quality
assurance inspector check it however in
2019 Boeing began laying off quality
assurance inspectors in favor of
so-called verification optimization
using less staff and more Technology
Solutions reportedly 900 inspectors were
laid off over 2 years a decision the
Boeing Workers Union said was
shortsighted without without considering
the long-term consequences it turns out
it didn't take that long to see the
consequences thankfully no one died on
this occasion and it should be an easy
issue to fix but it just shines another
light on Boeing's recent company culture
people claim this change in attitude is
due to business Executives leading an
engineering company but honestly I think
that's just self- congratulatory
nonsense from Engineers Dennis
mullenberg the CEO during the 737 Max
crashes was an engineer by training
business majors do not have a monopoly
on corporate greed Engineers are
perfectly capable of it two Boeing has
amazing engineers and produces amazing
products I have made an entire video
gushing over the master class of design
that is the 787 but there has been a
systemic issue of prioritizing revenue
and executive paychecks over customer
safety and employee job security I think
it's fair to say that a company with
this much risk and responsibility over
Public Safety needs more regulatory
oversight and asking for an exemption
from a safety standard is a pretty clear
sign that even the regulations that are
in place are not being
respected speaking of plugs you can
watch that entire 1hour long 787 video
ad free on nebula right now nebula is
the home of YouTube's best Aviation
channels from Mustard's incredible
nebula exclusive doc documentaries on
the B2 and f117 or our entire five-part
Battle of Britain series showing you in
intricate detail how Britain strategized
their most impactful victory of World
War II nebula is full of exclusive
content that you can't get on YouTube
along with our entire catalog without
any ads you can also easily download
videos to watch on the go by signing up
to nebula you are directly supporting
this channel in the most effective
manner for less than the price of a cup
of coffee you can get monthly access to
all of this this channel depends on the
funding nebula provides us if you've
been subscribed to this channel for more
than 3 years you've seen the huge
increases in production quality that
nebula has facilitated growing from 2D
animations that myself and Mike taught
ourselves how to do to having a full
team of incredibly talented 3D artists
that rival any TV production this is
expensive work and we would love to grow
our team even more something we can only
do with your support as YouTube ad
Revenue simply does not cover the bills
so if you want to check out all of the
fascinating exclusive content on nebula
go to